the m1 ultra in the mac studio really  beat out intel's 12 900k in nvidia's rtx  3090 starting out with geekbench 5 the  alder lake ship does beat out them on  ultra in single core performance but  then if we take a look at multi-core  performance the m1 ultra smokes it by  about 40 percent but if we go ahead and  take a look at a cinebench this is where  as long as you can give enough cooling  to this elder lake chip actually beats  the m1 ultra by about nine percent now  what about graphics we have to talk  about the rtx 3090 that apple kept  referencing we do have a benchmark that  came out it's gfx bench but  unfortunately the results that we have  is a score of  484 frames per second we have a couple  scenarios the 64 core model is thermally  limited the other option could be that  this result was the bend 48 core model  that costs a thousand dollars less